[Música]
es curioso como la mayoría de las veces
no en nuestra vida no somos conscientes
de la huella que alguien puede dejarnos
yo me acuerdo en segundo de carrera que
fui a un examen y siempre como todo el
mundo pensaba a ver lo que me van a
poner no y cuando cogí el examen a que
el examen hablaba de gente como el
chiquito de la calzada
manuel ruiz de lopera
y se me quedó en la mente de repente
aquel examen me cambió un poco la vida y
es curioso porque pasó hace pues 14 años
12 años prácticamente
y el 30 de julio recibí un mensaje a
través de facebook de aquel profesor que
en su momento me dejó totalmente marcado
y que persiste hasta ahora
y por eso estoy aquí se puede decir que
estoy aquí por chiquito de la calzada
manuel ruiz de lopera y por el señor
david silva que era mi profesor
y de repente cuando me llamaron
pues lo primero que hice fue llamar a mi
mejor amigo vale
con él escribo muchos guiones estos
muchísimos proyectos
me han llamado para dar una charla te lo
quiero hablar sobre redes sociales sobre
narrativas transmedia sobre fenómenos
fan y claro su respuesta no fue lo que
yo esperaba no les recuerdo que me dice
tío estás jodidos pero
hoy en día nadie tiene tiempo todo el
mundo habla de las redes sociales
bastante mal yo creo que debería de
buscar otro otro tema no yo le di las
gracias le colgué
y dice lo que todo médico te dice que no
hagas cuando te duele algo que buscar en
google
y busqué en google y de repente me
encontré con unos titulares
ostias
algunos de ellos dicen que el 83% de los
usuarios en redes sociales piensan que
lo que se dicen es mentira se hablaba de
cosas tan tan bestias como jóvenes
enganchados más a las redes sociales que
la droga o que las redes sociales son
uno de los motivos principales por lo
que la gente puede llegar a suicidarse
oa tener algún tipo de problema mental
claro imaginaos cómo me sentía
no sé si muchos de vosotros habéis visto
breaking bad pero yo en ese momento me
sentí como walter white en el desierto
que hago aquí y de repente apareció una
señorita que se llama jordi pitarque y
esta señorita es una profesora de lmt se
dedica a estudiar y se dedica a estudiar
gran parte de su vida como las
tecnologías en las redes sociales nos
están cambiando como personas nuestras
formas de comunicarnos nuestras formas
de comportarnos y una frase que me dejó
totalmente marcado igual que el examen
del chiquito esta frase me dijo
absolutamente en shock me hizo pensar
mucho no es como es curioso como cada
vez más tenemos la sensación de que
nadie nos escucha alguno de vosotros ha
tenido esa sensación alguna vez
claro nos parece incongruente es decir
estamos en el mundo más tecnológico más
conectado desde que se inventó internet
allá por los años 70 la tecnología y las
redes sociales nos están pasando por
encima unos niveles que si veis cómo se
produjeron las revoluciones industriales
os daréis cuenta que la última nos ha
pillado había cambiado y de repente dije
bueno si estamos en el mundo más
conectado en el que tenemos más
posibilidades de comunicación con los
demás qué es lo que ocurre no bueno pues
como todo profesor viejales que viene
hoy a enseñaros algo decidí traer unos
cuantos datos estos son algunos datos de
la gente que se conecta internet de la
cantidad de personas a nivel mundial y
en españa vale puesto a la paella porque
me parece interesante
pero hay una cosa que me llama la
atención de estos datos es a nivel
global prácticamente el tiempo de media
que dedicamos a estar conectados casi 7
horas
en españa son 5 horas 18 minutos
aproximadamente los días son muchas
horas al día
y si hablamos de redes sociales ya ni
los cuentos facebook millones de
usuarios a nivel global usuario nivel en
españa pero hay una cosa que yo que he
sido alumnos como muchos los que estáis
aquí cada vez que un profesor me ponía
unos datos memoria del asco literal
me sentía totalmente apartado entonces
sí que me gustaría hacer un pequeño
experimento para que veáis de manera
visual lo que tenemos hoy en día en
nuestros bolsillos aquí entra la parte
que david me ha introducido amablemente
no ustedes si pueden bajar un poquito
las luces del escenario que lo
agradecería mucho y que todo sacar en el
teléfono móvil podéis sacar el teléfono
móvil me gustaría que encendiera en la
linterna vale y la proyectará hasta aquí
todos me siento tan ganas literal
fijaos vale es brutal lo que acabáis de
conseguir imaginaos
cada uno de los puntos yo creo que esto
es algo muy visual y es muy importante
porque cada uno de los puntos
sois una puerta de acceso una puerta de
comunicación sin límites sin límite
temporal y sin límite espacial vale
muchísimas gracias podéis quitar los
teléfonos
y volvió de nuevo la pregunta y la frase
de la profesora es el target cada vez
nos sentimos
que no se escuchan menos pero claro
fijaos la cantidad de luz que habéis
todos producidos con vuestro teléfono
móvil
y de repente dije qué pasa con el
término transmedia el término transmedia
que como 'david bien ha comentado es un
término que a nivel audiovisual está
totalmente de moda parece que todos los
proyectos si no son transmedia parece
que no existen pero que hablamos cuando
hablamos de transmedia vale para un
curso muy rápido son aquellas historias
que somos capaces de contar en distintos
formatos son capaces son historias que
se expanden en distintos formatos y en
distintas plataformas
uno de los últimos trabajos que hice que
no se siguen muchos lo conocéis el
ministerio del tiempo no sé si conocéis
alguno en la serie si no tenéis un
poquito de trabajo y el ministerio el
tiempo consiguió una cosa muy
interesante que era de repente ese
universo se expandió en la historia no
sólo se contaba en la serie de
televisión sino que esos mismos
personajes viajaban al cómic viajaban al
podcast viajaban a las redes sociales y
a partir de ahí se empezaba a generar
una comunidad brutal que se llama en los
ministerios que han hecho unas
verdaderas barbaridades y locuras en
todo este tiempo no pero claro esta
manera de contar historias nace de el
avance de la tecnología es decir hoy
todo el mundo de un teléfono móvil yo
tengo un smart watch ipad todo el mundo
consume todo cuando quiere dónde quiere
y como quiere por tanto si un personaje
nos gusta lo más interesante sería no
sólo dejarlo en televisión sino poderlo
llevar un videojuego llevártelo la
realidad virtual o lo que fuese no
nosotros obviamente con el ministro del
tiempo no hemos inventado esto ni
inventado la pólvora realmente se ponga
algunos ejemplos más los reconozca es un
poco más esto star wars vale yo soy un
friki de hardware pero garza
fijaos todo lo que hay de star wars es
que hay prácticamente de todo hay
películas videojuegos todo el universo
que se ha generado alrededor de ellos y
hay uno quizá un poquito más claro que
harry potter
la gente habla de nostalgia
yo empecé con harry potter en los libros
pero harry potter también se convirtió
en un parque temático también se ha
convertido en varitas yo tengo una
varita de harry potter en el salón de
casa se ha convertido en dulces de
repente todo alrededor y todas esas
historias se cuentan de distintas formas
de una forma en la que muchos de
vosotros estaréis acostumbrado a
consumir uno de los grandes referentes
es pokemon que también funciona de esta
manera pero que hay algo importante
alrededor de todo esto alrededor de todo
esto y una cosa muy importante y es
aparte de las de las fotos aparte de los
dibujos aparte de los actores son los
nexos de unión vale son los nexos que
unen cada una de las partes que lo que
hacen es que funcione como algo potente
y ahora vamos a lo que he hablado
anteriormente es posible a través de la
narrativa transmedia es posible a través
de estas relaciones entre dispositivos
relaciones entre gente conectada generar
una conexión real una conexión física
entre la gente bueno esta es la pregunta
que me hago cada día que trabajo en
televisión y trabajo en producción de
nuevos nuevos formatos y hace unos meses
hace un par de meses
malaka una serie
málaga protagonizada por maggie civantos
por vicente romero y por salva reina y
había una cosa muy interesante en esta
serie era que tú leían los guiones
todas las frases eran andaluzas todos
los centros son andaluces todos los
actores son andaluces se ha rodado en
lugares donde ninguna cámara entra como
el barrio de la palmilla muy muy
conflictivo de málaga y un barrio que
digámoslo claro parece olvidado
en el ámbito más político más
gubernamental pero esa serie hablaba de
verdad entonces si recuperamos aquel
titular el principio de las charlas la
que decía que la gente piensa que en
redes sociales se miente más que en la
vida real nosotros empezamos a construir
alrededor de la serie una comunicación
un universo en un contacto con el fan
que hablaba de esa realidad de esa
realidad que mostraban los guiones y que
mostraba la serie y lo hicimos a través
de la cuenta de instagram solo teníamos
ese reducto y a partir de ahí la gente
empezaba a hablar con nosotros siempre
comentábamos con la gente hablábamos en
los comentarios
respondíamos se empezó a crear un
vínculo muy especial
yo soy andaluz yo soy de cádiz de
desarrollo de un pueblo y siempre pienso
que andalucía no se le da exactamente el
lugar que le corresponde no a la frase
yo recuerdo cuando fui a madrid cuando
empecé allí la gente me decía no no te
entiendo no es cómo pero si hablo el
mismo lenguaje no y de repente en malaca
veíamos frases maravillosas y ejemplos
maravillosos y dijimos oye si quedamos
con diccionario de andaluz qué pasaría
con ediciones de andaluz hicimos cosas
tan maravillosas como estas
pero es una cosa de málaga lleva lechuga
tomate la muestro que los montes madrid
que montan está cuarto
y
o seguimos
este uno de los personajes y también
esté muerto morir o muerto matado en una
constitución arios
al llegar y descubrir un cadáver y
quiere decir porque han muerto murió él
solo porque ha muerto matado por alguien
bueno fácil no de repente málaga fue
trending topic pues porque se hablaban
andaluz
y era maravilloso que con un diccionario
consiguiéramos cosas tan increíbles como
esas no se hizo vial la gente hablaba
del diccionario de malaca y nada que de
repente puso en órbita la gente conocía
al barrio del parque es tan conflictivo
como la palmilla conocía barrios que lo
que nunca nadie entraba los conocía a
través de una serie de televisión y
hablábamos de verdad y hablamos de esa
capacidad de estar con la gente y
pasaban cosas tan maravillosas como
estas algunos fans que nos mandaron pues
nos pedían los guiones y les pasábamos
los guiones y se los mandamos a casa
hubo otro chico que nos escribió que
gracias a la serie había descubrió su
vocación de ser actor que a partir de
ahora estaba haciendo un casting gente
de barrios que probablemente de ninguna
otra forma podríamos haber tenido acceso
a ellas a través de los teléfonos
móviles de las redes sociales e incluso
aquí hay un pequeño detalle un pequeño
regalo que le hicieron a maggie
en agradecimiento a su personaje blanca
pero bueno creo que muchos de vosotros
me diréis ya claro pero tú estás
hablando aquí de cosas
en internet de cosas que no son reales
de cosas que no son físicas pero hay una
cosa y hay un truco en estas charlas y
es que el motivo real de esta charla
está en este escenario probablemente nos
habéis dado cuenta pero estáis detrás
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno estos son dos libros
que tengo en casa que probablemente sean
los libros más importantes que yo tengo
en mi casa y tengo cientos de libros me
flipa leer pero son unos libros que son
especiales por algunos motivos uno de
ellos el listing de puertas secretas del
ministerio del tiempo es una
recopilación hecha por un fan de todas
las historias que habían creado la gente
a través de internet de nuestros
personajes él decidió editar un libro y
nos lo mandó hay solo dos copias en el
mundo de este libro una vez tiene el
creador de la serie y otra tengo yo en
agradecimiento me lo mandó pero hay otro
que esto es cada vez que me hace sonreír
la verdad se llama tradición pesquera es
un libro sencillo autoeditado que yo
probablemente nunca había comprado
no me interesaría el tema habría pasado
de largo pero un libro que me mandó un
fan a casa de malaca de la serie mal acá
era un chico de hecho leo aquí que se
crió en el barrio malagueño del bulto
que no sé si algunos lo conoceréis pero
es un barrio pues bastante conflictivo
al nivel de la palmilla él había
autoeditado y había guardado sus
memorias de como desde pequeño con 14
años se subía al barco y se ponía a
pescar y a faenar no en el libro cuenta
que dio amigos morir que bueno pues que
de repente su vida su trocito de vida
está aquí no y claro cuando yo lo abrí
la verdad dice para mi amigo pablo al
que había que ponerle cara con cariño y
más hay personas que no salen en la
pantalla pero su labor es encomiable y
su trabajo vale tanto como el del mejor
actor claro
este libro tiene un valor incalculable
porque gracias a él yo me di cuenta que
el trabajo que hacemos en televisión el
trabajo que hacemos en la producción
cuando creamos esas pequeñas comunidades
de fans regalamos nuestro tiempo a ellos
para escucharlos para comentarles para
estar siempre al día al final se traduce
en algo tan importante como esto no les
parece que es antiguo pero a mí la
verdad es que tener estos dos libros en
casa me representan de creo que vas
haciendo vamos haciendo las cosas bien y
viniendo aquí me vino a la mente otra
fotografía de otro de los momentos de
los que yo he vivido trabajando con
comunidades de fans y es este
esta fotografía está tomada en un rodaje
que hicimos con fans de la serie del
ministerio del tiempo entre la segunda y
la tercera temporada no paraban de
pedirnos hacer un rodaje e ir a los
rodajes claro imaginados son cientos de
miles de fans queriendo venir al rodaje
dijimos bueno vamos a crear una
secuencia en la que estéis 50
representando a los fans de la serie en
dos días recibimos como 7000 8000
peticiones para venir una barbaridad
pero esta foto y una cosa que realmente
para mí es el recuerdo más imborrable de
esta serie es marcano aquí una chica
aquí
mike a esta chica de aquí una de las
grandes fans de la serie que nos
escribió diciendo que quería venir pero
que no sabía si estaba en buena posición
de venir porque porque estaba en silla
de ruedas y lo primero que se nos
ocurrió lo primero que se nos pasó por
la cabeza era porque alguien en
silla de ruedas no puede trabajar en el
ministerio del tiempo
no porque alguien no estaría ahí y
montamos todo el despliegue para que esa
persona pudiese venir aquí fue mágico de
repente el tiempo que yo había dedicado
a escuchar escuchar a la gente se
convirtieron en los sueños de ella
esta chica murió hace seis meses antes
de dar la noticia de que estamos con la
nueva temporada y hoy me parecía el
lugar adecuado de hacerle el homenaje es
decir esta persona para mí representa lo
que creo que es esta charla es decir mi
tiempo entregado a otras personas a
través de donde sea de los dispositivos
que sean aunque por mucho que digan que
el internet y las redes sociales pueden
ser peligrosas usadas de buena forma han
cumplido sueños y creo que es bonito
terminar pensando que quizás en ese
mundo en el que muchos dicen que cada
vez nos escuchamos menos podamos a
partir de hoy escucharnos más y hacer
realidad sueños como personas como maika
como david como los autores de estos
libros
[Aplausos]
ah